A red iPhone? What? Matty are you excited about this? This is big news! Big news!
Yeah.
So the red iPhone actually been rumored for quite a while
and I don't know if anybody really
thought it was ever actually going to
happen because that's what happens
rumors but it's here. Yesterday it was
announced that the red iphone is a thing
and it's going on sale this friday at 8:01
am. I've been getting so many messages
and tweets and texts i woke up yesterday
morning--the day of the announcement-- and
it was just screen shots of the apple
website. hey did you see this? are you
going to get one? what do you think? I
absolutely love the red product line
because not only do they look really
freaking cool but it's also for a really
good cause so props to Apple for doing
this. They've been doing it for quite a
while and this iPhone actually looks a
lot like the red ipod they had a while
back here's ipod nano looks pretty good
and you know they're going for that similar
theme. A lot of the criticism was
that it didn't have a black front and I'm
going to be completely honest with you i
am a huge fan of the black front phones
and that's one of my biggest complaints
on the color phones is the white around
the edges. I like having a completely
flushed phone seamless and beautiful
which is why I decided to go with the
jet black phone. I mean this phone would of looked
so good with an all black front but
it makes sense because it's kind of in
their product line of this is how they
have been doing things for quite a while.
I hope this is a joke that didn't
actually ever happen, right? A special
one-of-a-kind collector's piece. Thank.
God. I'm sure you guys are all subscribed
to MK PhD because he actually had a red
iphone in his hands in an official
unboxing already and it looks really
really good you guys want to check that
out I'll put a link in the description and
my question to you guys is do I get it? I
mean it looks really, really good. The thing
is most people probably who are going to
get a 7 plus have probably already got
their 7 plus, so this is something I feel
like if you will have held out for the
newer phone that aren't quite ready to
upgrade to the next version that will be
coming out after this and I feel like
that's probably the market that this is
for or people who just really really
like red but this is the thing too I
can't not have a case on my phone
because I am completely reckless as you
guys
have seen in the past, so really unless
you have a red case on it no one's even
going to know that you have a red phone
because the front of it it's a little
silver button. They did that I know on the
gold phone because I have that one for
quite a while. The ring around the touch
ID button it matched the phone, so man that
would have been so cool and if you don't
want to buy an entirely new phone you
can just get a red case and still have that
same feel. They've also got a smart
battery case for the iPhone 7, so if you do
have one of these smaller phones there
you go that's for you. I'm surprised they
haven't made the larger version of this.
Got the red apple watch sports band. That
looks so good. I bet that would look so
good on... oh not wearing my watch. it's
charging currently. That would so good
with the ceramic base! we'll just skip
over the beats because those look not
like something I'm into so in case you
don't want to buy an entirely new phone
you can get an iPod Shuffle. I
didn't even know that they were still
selling those. i love the ipod nano i
thought it was just so cool and you got
some red cases for your ipad let's
take a peek at the models and pricing
and see how much these things are going
to run us so if you buy it without a
carrier you've got a 128 and 256 so the 236 is
969 dollars and i would definitely
recommend getting applecare because mistakes were made and i did not get it. I've
shattered my phone way too much. So an
iphone 7 without a carrier $849 that's
not even that much less than the seven
plus so that's silly like I'm not going
to lie like it looks good so apple's press
release here we've got the iphone 7, iPhone 7 plus and then they also announced a
new 9.7 inch ipad. This is interesting
apples quiet ipad launch proves no one
cares about tablets yeah that franchise
has gone from headlining marquee Apple events
to showing up at a quiet
announcement via press release well
here's the problem i mean i feel like
there are so many tablet options now
that it's really cut through that
market and be sort of something that is
stand out. Ipad definitely started it
all. They really pushed that tablet market
into what it is today and
now it's time for something else. the
iphone 7 plus is so huge that most
people that probably would be using an
ipad and have an iphone 7 plus there
really is no point in having the ipad as
well and now with the nintendo switch - it's just
another thing to carry. (referring to switch:) Oh I had a scratch!
oh no the last time an iPad felt
truly special was back in 2011 when
Steve Jobs came back from medical leave
to unveil the ipad 2 and again before
competitors flooded the market with
cheaper tablets and with things like the
microsoft surface I mean you're getting
an entire computer and also a tablet all
sort of in one and I still feel like the
iPad does not have a full working
operating system it still is iOS that's
a problem I'm not going to be able to
make that Ipad pearl into a full
working computer because it's not.
even though Apple is pushing that agenda
For most people who are doing normal
everyday things yeah you can completely
get away with it other people who aren't
doing things like that like the
professional market line it's not going
to work. So This is pretty interesting too.
apple also announced a clip video apps
I'm excited to see how this goes Apple
has tried to become social in the past
but I think like iTunes Connect or
something you guys remember that hey I'm
editing this video right now and I
remembered what it was called it was itunes
Ping didn't even remember that i can always liked 2012 I want to say
2011/2012. I remember adding friends and
I was so excited for like two days and
then just didn't ever touch it again so
you can't really technically compare it
to snapchat or Instagram it's basically
its own standalone app so it's kind of
like those things that you see on
facebook like the flat down cooking
videos people always adding cool
subtitles and kind of making a sort of
an interactive thing because a lot of
those videos they don't usually have
audio at first you have to turn those on
which is why subtitles and things like
that are very very important supposedly
this will add live titling we all know
how the youtube subtitles works not only
that accurate so I'm hoping that this is
definitely a little bit better than that
catch your a moment hold to record say
it and see it live title will see as we
create animated captions just by talking
issue
man hope it works hope it works pick a
filter drop it in emoji I want to see
more coming soon but when we need to
know when see here we go okay you're
making a little clip we're here moving
day it looks pretty cool and I have high
hopes because honestly you know Apple
when they do things right they do things
right it's crazy how things that when I
first started making videos and editing
in graphic design an extremely long time
ago I was probably in like sixth grade
when I started trying to figure out how
to use macromedia fireworks anybody
remember oh my goodness you know I only
had 30 day free trial I'd have to format
my computer every 30 days because I
didn't know how to you know hack it so
that I could i was i was at that time I
was like 10 it fit things were not like
they are now at all so I just thought
that's what I had to do and I didn't
have a job I was a child and my mom was
not going to be paying thousands and
thousands of dollars for software
because that's just crazy it was hard
enough to convince her that for my
birthday I want a gram obviously things
have changed significantly and I love
right now right now is such an
incredible time for technology I know a
lot of you guys are probably the age
that I was when I probably first was
getting into coding I was in sixth grade
I don't know how old you are in sixth
grade maybe like 11 or 12 and the first
time that I figured out how a website
was made I was at Nintendo com I went to
view source and it's my eyes a
wonderment when this page of text was
just performing so I would take some of
that text from other websites and I
would take it into one of those free web
site hosting things where you could sort
of just drop in HTML and then see what
it looks like there's ads everywhere so
I would like to copying and pasting code
from other websites just trying to see
how it worked and now you don't have to
really do any of that which is kind of
crazy but I'm super excited for you guys
and the future and everything awesome
that you guys are going to get to
experience because
it's going to be so cool i guess the
burn this whole video to a close of
course i always ramble when I do these
types of videos let's see what was i
even talking about the red iphone i'm
also searching for zelda recipes because
i'm going to be spoiler hello making
some zelda food if you guys have been
playing zelda let me know if there's any
recipes that you would like me to make
keep it simple i'm probably thinking
more along the lines of like a meat and
mushroom skewers so I tracked sidetracks
so yeah iphone 7 iphone 7 plus in red i
have a video coming out next week with
my new friend sarah DG she's so cool and
we did sort of an iphone 8 wish list so
that will be out next week and this was
all before this whole red iphone kind of
came out so we definitely don't make any
mention too that for good reason because
it didn't happen yet at the park opens
to employees in April let me check this
out am I an employee no will I ever be
no can I get a visitation can I have
visitation right probably not please and
just to reiterate I don't work for them
they've never paid me they've never told
me to say anything that I'm saying I am
just a true fan much love nah man as
this video so i can sublease Elda by the
centerpiece of the party is the question
Joey please join go you click here oh
yes which